this might be an old wives tale as well
or an older version of this the unhappy
writer is having more depth in which to
write about more and more in which to
pull from whereas the happy writers are
just scratching the surface and it might
be too much movie of the week instead of
something that pulls at your sort of
emotional core and you put yourselves in
the the characters shoes I don't know
again is that does that can we just
spell that then that you have to be
unhappy in that sense yeah you know this
is a famous dilemma
that people have been talking about for
my whole lifetime there was a book that
came out years and years ago called the
drama of the wood you have to try Alice
Miller yeah and thank you for a very but
but it's a very very interesting book
and it basically says that writers
should fear therapy because it might
Farah pies you know take away their
their angst from which came all of their
you know their brilliant ideas and it's
just they're simply not true
because there's just too many examples
of productive writers who have plenty of
inks and one of my favorite examples of
Stephen King who published in my
magazine DreamWorks we sent out a letter
to artists all over the world including
him and said could you please tell us
whether dreams have any influence you
know on your creativity and if so give
us an example of a dream and in a
creative work that came from us for cup
came from it so Fellini sent us a
cartoon that he dreamed in the middle of
the night that led to eight and a half
his movie eight and a half and we got
great stuff from all kinds of people and
Stephen King finally up six months later
after everyone else sent us a very short
letter and he said this is my constant
nightmare I am sitting alone an attic
typing away and a little door on the
floor of the attic opens and a hideous
face comes out of the door and I start
typing as fast as I can because because
the faster I type the more the door
closes
and if I slow down you know the face
keep coming out and he says does that
count and you know it's an example of
what you're talking about because he has
plenty of angst going on he has plenty
of terror and fear and dark things in
his some of his most brilliant works
like the Shawshank Redemption and you
know of the shining and he's not an
unhappy writer like he's he knows that
he needs to put the time in every day
he's figured it out and he's prolific
and so on so there's just too many
examples of balanced writers let's call
the mentally balanced writers one of my
favorite statements from the world of
art is Salvador Dali said one time the
difference between myself and a madman
is that I am not mad yeah I love that
because only an artist who knows how
close sanity is to insanity knows what
that beans you know Aquis he's one of
those madmen who isn't mad whereas a lot
of other bad men are mad and you know
okay they kill themselves or they kill
somebody else or whatever so it's it's
all about knowing yourself I mean it's
all about figuring out how your mind
works and proving it and testing it
until you know that before you know it
you look back and you go oh my god I've
written you know all these books all
these things going on and I don't think
I'm crazy and on the other hand I don't
think I'm saying either
you know it's it's like you've just
figured it out and so you can doesn't
mean you're not having dark spells it's
just that you you kind of look at your
dark spells from the outside instead of
from the inside
you know they it's very common in
meditation and yoga to understand that
you can either be inside yourself all
the time
and drive yourself crazy by letting your
mind run it you know what's going on or
you can like stay above your mind and
look down on all these thoughts going by
and all this stuff and
recognize that you the one looking is in
charge not all the thoughts and the
writers time has a whole theory about
how the creative mind works that way
where there's what I call the managing
editor looking at the the fight going on
inside your mind and realizing that this
can be controlled if you trick the two
sides of the mind and force them to work
together that's kind of what it's all
about to become productive and happy at
the same time
and it you know seems to work for a lot
of people
you